good morning John's Pizza maths a long
long time ago when we started to make
just one video a week each on the vlog
with this channel the idea was to free
up some time for us to do some other
stuff and that has 100% happened right
like this very weekend the farmers
market somebody like tapped me on the
shoulder and said hey are you the author
Hank green and as I usually do I said no
that's my brother John and then they
said actually I think you're wrong
like I just finished reading your book
it was really good yeah I guess I'm the
author Hank green I hadn't really sunk
in in that way yet novelist so it worked
but also switching to just one video a
week made it feel like a lot more
pressure to make that one video we could
be really super good and if it wasn't
that I felt bad about so it's like less
work but more pressure almost which I
think is a totally fair trade it's also
one of the reasons why I really love
pizza miss because this time of the year
I got to make a lot of videos and so
you'll probably be a little more
understanding if not all of them are
very good it's the time of the year when
we can get away with like not having
like a super fancy dance break in the
middle why is there music playing right
now why is there music playing right
okay fine
[Music]
meter system into mice jumpy and it's
too tight you feel it in your soul when
the grooves nice you wanna know what I'm
like I can't dance I can't dance I can't
dance I can't dance but as I was saying
before I was so rudely interrupted by
that fashion shoot dance Bree meets a
mrs. really important time of the year
for me because it gives me a chance to
concentrate not like on the more
complicated parts of the stuff that I do
but on something a lot more simple like
just sharing what's on my mind like for
example I would have the dermatologist
cuz I had a face rash and he was like
well while you're he let me look over
see if you got any problematic looking
moles and one on the bottom of my foot
and y'all bottom of the foot moles turn
out to be oftentimes really dangerous
because one people don't look at the
bottom of their feet very often and two
people think well it's just a bottom of
the foot mole that can't be that bad but
it turns out it's one of the more
dangerous kinds of cancer footballs so
he used his magic knife and he took it
out of my body and then he looked at it
in the lab and confirmed that it was
indeed just a normal mole but I'm glad
that I had it looked at John's not just
something that happens to old people I
also got a flu shot while I was there
flu shots are good for you you should
get yours I didn't even feel it man they
made the needle so tiny now also John
I've been thinking a lot about soup
that's the whole sentence also my wife
and I have a podcast called delete this
where we discussed my social media usage
and it turns out like it's been a really
good thing for me and also assists a ton
of fun Kaji's alaria also I'm a little
worried about democracy also it's spring
in the southern hemisphere of Mars which
means that the carbon dioxide deposits
under the surface are ripping through
the ice above them into magnificent
geysers of gas and dust and that's
really a thing that happened also my son
just turned 2 he's a two-year-old John -
what's also plants are made of air
rather than seem right John but it's
true and this shirt is made of plants
and so this shirt
made of air it's made of eight also John
Pizza miss I'll see you on Wednesday
tomorrow I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]